by Rubio box euro-step and the basket Oh
first bucket knocks it down here and box
with the Euro step and deliver Mitchell
now in double figures although he's
shooting percentage is not good as I was
just saying buddy le box
Oh Fox in open court is he honest
[Applause]
and any game any player he'll finds his
way inside and able to finish off the
kimono one do just what you did Steven
Adams this right here's this a tough
finish point with the way bound Fox look
go look at dear
[Applause]
boy you talk about electricity
look at that move emphatically the
recipient of that great assist that's 13
assists for their and function as yet
they haven't stepped on the gas pedal
back leaves from healed what a beautiful
pass my stead as we take a look at right
here a nice little pass down to Buddy
hield back I think that's fatigue : how
best will have where did [ __ ] there's so
much this how many how many dribbles
three dribbler xana-don't
three triples and a dunk and only one
dribble on that side a half-court that
is a while two minutes to play whoa has
it gone
come this way box all the way to the
road so these happens buddy hield
setting up :
it takes a lot of time off the 5:30
field fine and Willie cauley-stein up
top with the throwdown
throw it up I tried down uses wind L
bounces back to him knocked away and
stolen by the Aaron Fox he is off to the
races and dumpster there
and there's a nice John my buddy hield
that's just all leopard does that would
be a solid EBU look at that put some
cheese and bake it on that burger you
say trying to hold the young guys
accountable defensively yes
[Music]
it's kinda like grant oh oh oh my
goodness did we just say get it done
inside think you got it point-blank
thank you very much we're going the
other way look at mr. box up the bug
Tootie Troy Williams out of Indiana Bush
on the heel Don John Bagley in the
corner
[Applause]
right here grin he is filling our
Michael Jackson just beat it baby oh
goodness gracious and those are the type
of plays that get the King started the
fans are standing on their feet they'll
keep that play in mind if things turn
around here in the second quarter d
Aaron Fox no good long rebound the elite
Senapati healed
climbing the ladder and tripping at home
that chance but what more but he can say
I got a body this evening bang and hang
on a rim the rep will allow you to hang
on the rim as your touch everybody takes
full advantage of it
Jungle Jim time in golden one simply you
know what is for the guy with the ball
right now that that's what dougie has
four assists yes he is leaving for
finish and guess what he now has two
parts
look at this grin turn the corner up top
would I [ __ ] see you later
say what you want but he's going to keep
shooting takes it inside create some
contact on them wrap him up 108 103 you
know like NBA basketball oh the lane
look at this I use my speed little spin
cycle with the kiss mr. Fox delivers
whoa the trials just going to come in in
a moment now they switch out on buddy
hield
and at 79th back there ten on the clock
Fox Fox spinning Fox into the lane you
know let keeps basketball oh boy you've
been the one guy for the magic tonight
they can knock it down from outside oh
well the Globetrotters are coming into
town we'll go the other way
Jackson three-on-two box box
Oh if you don't like that you know like
Kings best
just don't jump this what they say yeah
yeah little pump basket
[Applause]
buddy we're almost washing
and it's down
count
and the kids get a miraculous wood in
the basket watch the timer was the
weigh-in time and it's down and the
Pistons stop and did not get it
tough tough laws the basket watch the
timer
was away in time and it's down you'll
need to come to life Fez Duncan comes up
another steal
but the errant fox racing down gets them
no speak he didn't accelerate here would
you don't accelerate in this game look
it's not like you're football kids got a
run 7258
Oh what about bunny to set up Shepherd
fighting watch the setup by Buddy hield
and it's am on Shumpert by the way that
balance process
[Applause]
let's take another beautiful pass by
Fox's site you're right some to get into
that box pulls it back out five seconds
on the 24 fox driving at Robertson has
to pay with the follow slabs of death
rising one-handed stuff this is what
happen when you don't block guys out to
get a running start to the west pressure
shot right so turning the corner defense
my buddy hill had the Aaron Fox all
about meet me at the summit here and Fox
goes up Oh give me that
and Bledsoe was going for the hammer and
Buddy hield over there as well with the
contest listen he'll takes it again very
salable house watch him right here I
mean all the way over here I love it and
here he is speaking of defense in the
steel with the lead
[Music]
well these guys have a lot of confidence
in their ability and they know that they
they still believe they got a chance at
the playoffs and then they play Mike and
that's what you want to see buddy hield
now with twelve eight Lee changes ten
ties box goodbye
you're a slam dunk contest 20 rating you
give him here here give him a tan on
that one and the steel even better but
the Aaron Jonah man there is just
nothing he can't do doughnuts with a
real sass
[Applause]
62-56 buddy hield
of xi and three nice drive using the
left hand against a
[Applause]
beautiful steel there the air and the
steps in the passing lane bouts a major
web each woman's lemon and Jim
points the Bennigan's Lakers have been
amongst the leaders most of the year
their garrison bar owner working on the
blonde wanted to go up and onto the
blonde he's given it buddy hield of
three rattles it in stop though they
done you can get split these bets does
it get a whistle buddy hield transition
of three
[Applause]
now he's going to drive it and this one
will bounce home after the last one
bounced out doctors victim he needed it
he stepped up st. faced with the Aaron's
bot
what up at your boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report